pft on yahoo sports peter king mike
florio here to discuss some of the big
stories in the national football league
and peter let's start with odell beckham
jr brown's receiver out for the year
torn acl suffered while trying to make a
tackle after an interception on sunday
gotta respect the effort unfortunately
he's finished for 2020. what does the
future hold for otto beckham jr either
with the browns or someone else
well mike i i mean the first thing you
have to think about is that next season
odell beckham will turn 29 years old
and so it's it's
you know as we do in this business
because you and i are kind of well i'm
an old man you're nearly an old man
we look at guys and
they last for a while and then all of a
sudden you look up one day and you say
wow the next time odell beckham uh will
be on the field in the 2021 season and
he turns 29 in november and you say wow
well next man up you know but
that has to be considered i think with a
guy like odell beckham jr he's taken
i'm not saying
any abnormal amount of hits or abuse
but the fact is you've got to factor in
the age when you talk about a guy who
has been in the league for a while so i
think that would be my first thing the
second thing is i really think this
depends how the brown season progresses
and how it ends
because
look
you know other than the dallas game this
year
mike
where odell beckham jr was a absolutely
dominant force in that game he's not
been a dominant force this season for
the cleveland browns so what happens if
they play great do well
and they want to save a few bucks on the
cap next year and i don't even know what
what the cab situation is
but i could see the browns moving on
from i'm not saying they will i'm just
saying i could see it if they have a
great year without them
and i think that that it becomes a
no-brainer if they thrive without them
and they should when you look at their
schedule they've got five more games
they should win if they beat the raiders
this week 11 and 5 is not out of the
question there's only three games left
for the browns that stand out as games
they should lose so if they make it to
the playoffs without otto beckham jr
they're looking at a salary of 14 and a
half million for next year that they
could avoid and there's not much in the
way of bonus acceleration in fact
there's none because he was traded from
the giants
and the giants took the cap hit when
that deal happened so this is something
that the browns could very easily do
they could trade him the question is
what would his value be we're not going
to know what his value is going to be
peter until we know whether or not he's
healthy that's where it becomes
complicated and i wonder whether or not
he may have even been traded this year
if he hadn't suffered the injury but i
think once he gets a clean bill of
health and once he proves that he can
run if and when that happens i think
that that the browns would be foolish
not to at least consider it and if they
get to the playoffs without him i think
it's going to make sense for them to do
it because having him around
has with it that constant pressure of
getting him the football and all that
chatter about did he get the football
and i'd like baker mayfield to just be
able to throw the open guy and i think
they can make that work without beckham
run the ball throw the open guy play
defense and they can win plenty of games
i totally agree and you know you think
of the trade value and everything he's
not going to have great trade value in a
year he turns
29
coming off an acl but the two teams that
i think who knows maybe they give a
three for him i don't know that you're
going to get much more than that but the
two teams would be new england and san
francisco because i think bill belichick
will enter this off season
understanding after getting punched in
the face this year you know going back
to late last year
you know hey mike
since in the last calendar year
you know the the new york j they know
the new england patriots are six and
nine
and
you know probably going to be six and
ten after playing buffalo this weekend
so that's a full season that's enough to
see
where your warts are and the biggest
warts the patriots have i mean obviously
if cam newton doesn't increase
significantly they're going to have to
get a quarterback but they have to get
reasonably priced skilled players that
is crucial
one way or the other i have a feeling he
won't be included next year we'll see
what happens with obj and we'll see you
next time for pft on yahoo sports
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports